robert spencer iran's list of
pre-negotiation demands
on the united states continues to grow
every week
and supposedly all must be met
as a precondition for iran re-joining
the jcpoa what is the biden
administration
thinking to consider
these demands primarily barry it's about
ego
trump showed them up he brought peace to
the middle east
he engineered accords between israel and
the uae
and bahrain and the other abraham accord
states
he showed that john kerry was wrong when
john kerry
said that you have to go through the
palestinians to bring about peace
between israel and any of the other
states surrounding it
now those people that foreign policy
establishment they're back in power
and they're mad and they have to show up
trump and show that he was wrong
and so they're going to go back to their
own failed policies from the past
from the obama years including the
iranian nuclear deal
and they've got to have it and they're
throwing they're staking our entire
future on it
confident that iran will turn out to be
benign and peaceful and that it will
redound to their benefit
or on the other hand maybe because
they're globalist socialist
internationalists
who hate uh the american tradition and
the judeo-christian tradition and so on
maybe they want to see the united states
fall
they certainly are acting in in no way
different from how they would be
if that were true if that were true
you